six one seven eight three zero forty
seven fifty let's go to our next caller
from the eight four seven area code 847
say hello tell us your name where you're
calling from and what your question is
today hi David my name is Ezra and I'm
from 847 Illinois I'm from the
Chicagoland area great and I I don't
have a question I just wanted to tell
you that me and my mom were both viewers
of your show and we just think that
you're fighting the good fight and that
you're great and so I just wanted to
call in and throw some love your way
Wow you know your your show is great and
yeah I'm uh I'm a patron on patreon and
my mom made a contribution when you
started the patreon a while back I think
that was like did you start that during
the winter yeah basically spring right
right and so yeah we're just supporters
of the show and yeah I just wanted to
tell you keep fighting the good fight
David absolutely thank you so much this
was not a staged phone call from Ezra
and Ezra hey I'm guessing that you are
finding patreon to be even better now
that the bonus show and the commercial
free show are available there oh yeah
it's it's super convenient yeah you know
the the patreon it's it's just a better
way to make being able to support like
whoever you know it's a more accessible
way so patreon so really good a platform
for that yep all right well listen Ezra
best caller ever thank you so much
appreciate the call and look forward to
hearing back from you love Chicago
Chicago's great thanks for the call very
very much appreciate it